also like clothes you can make friends
with them and then they'll go and like
bring you gifts they'll go like get
tinfoil things for you
[Music]
you bought [ __ ] 30 pounds of peanuts
yeah
because i was gonna bring them in the
next day
and like feed them
what do you think just fears the most
get honest like i was always kind of a
harsh [ __ ] right but like you guys made
me stronger just in the fact that i
finally kind of felt
loved too like i mean i have family and
stuff that love me but it's almost like
when the outside when someone outside of
your family can love you too then it
helps you feel like oh i am worthy of
love too and you guys have given me that
like man i really
only want to help people are like the
best for people and like so when i say
something that like makes them upset it
like really
like gets like uh
all you people watching need to stop
watching because you don't you didn't
earn this vulnerability
[Music]
hi everyone welcome back to another
episode of big mood as you can see we're
back in our computers because we're so
far away from each other and some of us
decide to have a baby
yep i did
so that's okay
um we're gonna have some fun today we
have you guys have seen an episode
before
where we uh we played
uh we're not really strangers but we
played the mobile version but i actually
have the physical game with me so we're
gonna play this and answer questions um
about ourselves about each other so that
you get questions like deep questions so
you guys can get us or get to know us
better and we can get to know each other
a little bit better uh all four of us
are here today uh sound off i'm gina hi
for those of you listening at home i'm
nikki hi
i'm tiff hey
i love it
and since i'm the only one with a
physical copy of the game here's how
we're going to do this uh we're going to
go down the line we're going to start
with whoever let's uh let's do
tiff nikki jess and then me okay
okay and then each person when it's your
turn you guys can decide which level
card you want to do level one which is
like a more like uh easier answer
shallow questions level two more like
friendship and you know a little bit
closer and level three which is very
very deep should we all do level three
then jess
everybody knows us we know us
okay
uh how do you guys want to do it we pull
the card and then the person who pulled
it you can just read it you can read it
for us but okay
and then no we're i'm going to drive to
your house and yeah like in like if i
pull a card for tiff does only tiff
answer it or do does stiff answer and
all three of us answer it i think it'll
say like it like do you think i'm this
and then that'll signal that we answer
it but sometimes it's like i have to
answer it i think you could you could
probably tell but we could figure it out
play about you yeah okay by the way not
sponsored but this game is really good
but can you guys please send us free
copies of the expansion packs
do you know where influencers have it
[Applause]
i'm not an influencer i'll post it for
you and you want to collaborate
all right tiff your card says
tiff is asking you guys what do you
recommend i let go of if anything
what should tiff let go of
control
i want you to let go of control
let go of control
that's a song for you too jess
i'm talking to myself
playing it she's playing that's our
spotify playlist
what
yeah say your past but then also the
same time your past made you who you are
today so it's not bad
i would say
um
yeah i mean like because i guess a more
specific form of
control the might like
like the little like micro things that
you can't really control you know
like you could you could still have
structure in your life i think that some
control is really good and like it makes
you feel like you have a pathway and
stuff but like maybe the little things
i agree how do you feel about our
answers i fully agree but honestly the
first thing when i said that's easy i
thought of my the past like i
i am like
i'm such a good friend
yeah so you nailed it
i'm so stuck in my in the past
particularly the past
part of resentment like i can't let go
of resentment towards a lot of people in
my life and that holds me back
in a lot of these areas maybe that's
what's manifesting the need to control
because it's like maybe if you could
control everything then you won't have
you won't build resentment for anything
yeah
you know
100 trying to protect yourself from what
happened back then oh yeah big time
again yeah
super super accurate
yeah so i would i would also say like
yeah the control and my past like all of
that is hundred percent what i really
need to let go and what i've been trying
to let go of and what i've been
every time i go to therapy i tell my
therapist like okay listen i know i'm
like this because of these things
how do i get over it like how do i
[ __ ] let go yeah no one has the
answer either right because it's like
yeah it's all inside of you because then
it's also really frustrating because in
therapy like a lot of times it's like
well see that's the first step like
realizing why you are the way you are or
would you do the things you do and it's
like i already like i've been and stuck
in the first step like how do i get to
the next step like how do i let go like
i want to move on and like [ __ ]
do you think it's true
like like
if i had say
a rocky relationship with nicki lima
green in the past
but now i trust her
to not hurt me again i think it would be
easier for me to let go of any
resentment mm-hmm
i'm making a stupid yeah i'm just like
making a statement
jess and i got in a really
dramatic fight it was like
really intense so like i think i think
maybe like if you could trust that
there's no future pain maybe or are you
holding on to resentment with someone
you don't even have in your life anymore
it's like resentment all around girl
like
just everywhere like even with myself
like resentment with my own past self
like my own decisions that like my own
actions and like that i i don't know
it's just really annoying i'm just so
over it i'm like oh just let it go but
you know what i will say that the
like the first step in
in learning how to let go has been my
experience my birth experience like how
i was just so
angry and like hurt and like
resentful of what what how
the birth plan panned out and the things
that i felt like that were like
happening without my wanting to and all
that right and i just had so many
emotions about it for so long it's been
four and a half five months and
the very first time in my whole life
that i ever like learned how to let go
because i'm like letting it go like i
don't feel that mountain of emotion
anymore it's because i actually figured
out that i have to allow myself to feel
those things and that's when i was like
[ __ ] mind-blown like like eureka
moment where i'm like oh so that's how
you do it like you have to let yourself
be mad and be
like feel it like feel the anger and
then be like
and that's it then you get exhausted by
it
yeah you found that
i'm like literally an infant stage of
this so that's why when you guys are
saying like i need to let go of that
stuff like i fully agree and i'm like
i just you're learning just yeah figured
out how to like even begin that process
and
so yeah that's nice i love that that's
thanks
yeah that's good
okay
um nikki
oh yes you're next your card says
what does nikki need to hear right now
that you're awesome and i'm so proud of
you and you did so good yeah i was gonna
say yeah probably something positive
cause i don't i don't think there's
anything like that you're kind of well
at least i personally don't know that
there's anything bad that you're going
through i feel like you're kind of on an
upswing now so i just want to be like
i'm so happy that you're doing better
now than you were like 12 months ago
like it makes me feel good that you're
not like
in pain as much as i feel like at least
i'm assuming yeah that you're not in as
much pain as you were previously and i'm
really happy for you about that mm-hmm
and then go buy the thing that you
always wanted to buy which i don't know
what it is but then there might be
something so go buy the thing because
you deserve spoil yourself you deserve
it like another robot bartender or an
ice cube or something yeah did you post
an ice cube baker that i knew i bought
the pebble ice maker it's like you got
it yeah the good idea 700 machine and
i'm like it makes frozen water but like
everything for you people by dms were
like yo i don't recommend splurging on
the ship but i did this and it it is
like honestly worth it like it's the
best thing that ever happened to me and
i'm like nice
it's a good purchase i feel good about
that well thank you yeah i um
i really
two years ago couldn't have predicted
that like i would be in such an awesome
place right now like i don't think i
think this is the happiest i've ever
felt in my life oh
yeah and like it's pretty big i know and
it took a lot to i mean if you read
through all of my journals like it's
just all depression and anxiety and all
kinds of like stuff and this is like the
first time where like i can honestly
write like really positively like that
i'm i've always been grateful for things
in my life but like right now i feel
like
there's a window of time in this era
where i love
everybody that i know i in my like in my
circle like friendships and
family and everybody's healthy and all
my cats are here and i have a husband
that loves me and i'm doing something i
really love and i'm thriving in it and
i just don't think all of those things
have ever come together oops at one time
and um also
after
i ran deep in that tournament a couple
weeks ago um my dad said he was proud of
me and he's only said that for the first
time i'm kidding for the second time in
my life
that's kind of [ __ ] up honestly yeah
you've done a lot of really cool [ __ ] i
know thank you think that he uh
i mean it's not his fault that he didn't
he didn't really understand youtube at
all like i remember being in youtube for
a while like
eight years when he like brought up like
hey there's like this event that like
maker studios is doing and
i was like dad i've been part of that
company for like five years and he's
like do you know what angry cat is and i
was like grumpy cat and yeah
so that's what you're doing huh and i
just realized that he just didn't really
grasp what i was doing
um but yeah i i remember just because my
brother
was an athlete um and my dad's an
athlete he was a baseball player and my
brother played football in baseball and
i just felt like he always told my
brother how proud he was of him and i'm
like over here getting like a 4.26 gpa
not cool enough like i got a scholarship
to college not cool enough i do you know
i was like just trying all the time like
a human doing because like i want
validation and um
i didn't really realize how much i
needed like validation
until i like got it and then the first
time he said he was proud of me i was 26
and i it was right before i was gonna go
on a red carpet so i was like
try not to cry and ruin my makeup but i
was like that is the first time he's
ever said that and he was like hey he
was like the [ __ ] up voice he was like
i know you never need to hear it because
you're like me and i realized why he
never said it is because he thinks that
i'm like him he's like i know you're
fueled more by people not believing in
you it looks like oh my god
it's the whole [ __ ] time
he was like he was your villain on
purpose yeah like you were like
you don't like people blowing smoke up
your ass you don't need it like you know
i've been proud of you but like i guess
i should say it you know and it was like
my [ __ ] whole life i never thought
you were proud of me but i didn't tell
him that
and so now the second time he's he said
yeah he was proud yeah he was like
you're really amazing i'm proud of you
and i was like
because it's like a sport like he was
reading all the articles that i was
getting written up in and he was like
whoa you beat out like
gold bracelet winners like p
professionals like this is he
understands sports also he's he's an
accountant so he understands that you
just won six figures yes that too
very much
he's like do they take the taxes out or
yeah
well he actually he said i'm proud of
you and also i'll be sending my invoices
for all the years i did taxes for free
and i was like there's a statute of
limitations actually so
i won't be paying those
oh
that's awesome
okay jess your card says
what am i or what is jess most qualified
to give advice about finances cars life
boys
emotions cars for sure not being a [ __ ]
um negotiating how to be a good friend
the biggest [ __ ] what do you mean no
yeah whenever i'm being a little [ __ ] i
call you is just all in terms of like
strength
yeah create the life you want yeah
karen's kind of a negative connotation
though that's like a
little racist twinge to it
i'm not gonna
accept that you're a susan
susan yeah i remember i was freaking out
about something i called jess i was like
and just like it's what that what i'm
like why are you so calm about this jess
no one [ __ ] cares
it's not a big deal but jess why are you
so calm
and later i was like yeah no one really
cares no
yeah you're so good in so many
aspects of things like i don't know
you're just knowledgeable believe that
though
on all of them
because i'm like i'm not good at talking
about guys because i don't have one
um you're telling us not to talk to guys
that are shitty that's what it is okay
there you go setting up i'm gonna help
i'm good at helping you avoid them i
guess
i think you're good at anything that you
actually get interested in you actually
want to do a thorough job researching it
and like examining both sides of things
i really appreciate that you look into
both sides of everything that you
actually research some people like just
go off in one direction they're like
well immediately this is bad and this is
good and like well i can understand both
sides yeah i know i definitely try to
take in a lot of information
yeah
you're a good person to go to to talk to
everything about honestly yeah you're
super knowledgeable every time that i'm
like always in a
in a confused state you make things so
clear to me you really get that yeah
and also you're really good at
motivating like
you motivate me you know it's
interesting and casey like every time we
have our conversation like whenever you
would come and sleep over and we'd talk
for a long time and i'm like
like casey and i are like you know what
we're [ __ ] motivated as [ __ ] like
jess just like just she just makes like
you just i don't know you like light a
fire underneath you're good in a good
way other like the outside perspective
like you're good at zooming out on other
people and like telling them exactly
what they need to do and why and here's
all the things like you helped me buy
this house like basically i mean you
didn't help me buy it but like you were
i wasn't gonna buy this house i was yeah
think of all the reasons not to and
you're like why and you like
examined it like we did a deep dive into
like what what is psychologically
preventing me from making an offer on
this house and i was like yeah you're
right i don't i don't know i think i'm
sabotaging myself because i
don't think i deserve great good things
and then uh yeah i think you're really
good at
pinpointing exactly what's going on with
other people
but not myself but not yourself maybe
but but i think by looking at other
people you can you can also use that to
reflect on yourself because you are good
at after you calm down from something
that you're going through to like you
know kind of zoom out and look at
yourself and be like i think this is
what happened and this is what's wrong
and
um yeah i think it's a really good
quality to have yeah well that's awesome
thank you
what do you want to eat tonight maybe
you want some home-cooked favorite but
don't feel like going to the store or do
you want something exciting and new but
it would be great to stay in doordash
connects you with everything you want
whenever and however you want it along
with the restaurants you love you can
now get groceries and other essential
items delivered with doordash get drinks
snacks and other household items in
under an hour i actually recently just
used doordash i ordered from target
while i was in a hotel and i was able to
get um i got a bunch of snacks i got
some rice krispie treats and i got some
doritos and i got some waters and it was
nice to have my hotel room stocked up
and doordash made it easy because
otherwise i would have had to take in a
car like a taxi to find a grocery store
and that's also difficult when you're in
a hotel doordash made that easy for me
for limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of fifteen dollars or more
when you download the doordash app and
enter code big mood that's 25 off up to
10 value and zero delivery fees on your
first order when you download doordash
app in the app store and enter code big
mood don't forget that's code big mood
for 25 off your first order with
doordash subject to change terms apply
gaps in your diet should not be ignored
okay ladies and gentlemen but also
ladies because over 97 of women aged 19
through 50 are not getting enough
vitamin d
from their diet and then the 95 are not
getting the recommended intake of key
omega-3s either it's kind of easy if you
know where to go such as rituals
essential for women 18 plus multivitamin
which was formulated by exhaustive
research to help fill nutrient gaps in
the diets of women 18 and over it's
formulated with nutrients to help
support brain health bone health blood
health and provide antioxidant support
yeah see what a little bit of d could do
for you but ritual doesn't stop there no
they invested in a gold standard
university-led clinical trial to prove
the impact of essential for women 18
plus multivitamin and you know what the
results were essential women 18 and plus
was shown to increase vitamin d levels
by 43
and omega-3 dha levels by 41
in 12 weeks the clinical study was
published in leading scientific journal
frontiers in nutrition you can read all
about it just like go do some minimal
googling and look at all the good stuff
ritual is doing it's so easy i've been
on ritual vitamins since
2017 or 18 i can't remember a long time
ago and then i got on the prenatal
vitamins two or three years ago and i
noticed just such a significant
difference i don't have chronic fatigue
anymore right now ritual is offering our
listeners 10 off your first three months
if you visit ritual.com big mood and
turn healthy habits into a ritual that's
10 off at ritual.com big mood my card
says
uh what about me most surprised you guys
i've told you this before oh yeah
yeah
maybe maybe
tip was surprised that i was nice yeah i
was so surprised she was nice i'm like
what you're really nice like you're so
pretty you have this like confident like
aura and you're so nice too
i was not used to that she's like
something's up i was so used to like
caddy [ __ ] like just like especially
when they're like really pretty like
really pretty girls
for some reason we're always so mean to
me
[ __ ] yeah but then gina was so [ __ ]
tender and like like just so sweet and
like immediately took a ring off her
finger and a gift gift to me on her
first meeting which i wish i still had
that ring i don't think i have anymore
but i like just i don't know i was just
i was so touched where i'm like wow
you're so yeah you're really warm energy
way warmer that i mean i didn't think
you'd be mean but i didn't expect you to
be so warm
it was like very welcoming right away i
was surprised when you came over to my
house like i mean i know you're nerdy
and i know that like you stream and
obviously you're you're professional
streamer but like the way you just broke
down all the freaking stream stuff i was
like
this [ __ ] knows technical [ __ ] i don't
i thought she was like comic book nerdy
like but the way that you're always like
we don't i don't want to participate in
the you know production aspect i want to
just do the creative i just picture you
like phoebe on friends and like
yeah like streams of consciousness
creatively come to me but not the
[ __ ] okay so you're gonna want to set
this up go to settings
[ __ ] i'm like who is this lady
it's only one thing it's only stream
stuff that's the only thing i know
anything else i'm [ __ ]
no you're pretty techy girl i mean
you're thinking bed is hella high tech
oh that's true i do love my battle yeah
all of your lights are like they like
talk to say gina's in the room and like
turn them off
oh yeah
what is it an amazon thing or something
yeah yeah you're alexa
alexa yeah that's cute i think what well
i mean we've already gone over kind of
like our initial reactions to one thing
that surprised me recently was when you
showed us you shared a show that you
were on on g4 and i watched your
performance and honestly i was blown
away i was like you [ __ ] did
you [ __ ] killed it oh thank you i
didn't realize like you could just like
off the cuff perform so
well i always thought you were just kind
of like i don't know what to say like i
just didn't i didn't picture you being
able to [ __ ] like get into a
character that well and actually do that
well so i was like really proud of you
oh that's so surprising good job thank
you yeah that makes me so happy to hear
i actually went into g4 really nervous
because i felt like
everyone else had years of experience i
mean like kasim has like 52 years on me
you know
and kevin has another 70 years on me you
know so it was very intimidating but i
gotta say i learned a lot while being at
g4 but then like all these years on
youtube and stuff definitely helped too
yeah it actually surprised me when you
said that you took an improv class for
the first time because i always thought
you're so good at improv like oh yeah
yeah you're kind of a natural like if
you i could totally see like just having
like two classes and you could like oh i
got the structure down and now you're
you're like so set but yeah you you're
so good at like off the cusp
on camera stuff yeah yay well i don't
like it conversationally but a character
like you played a character like that's
not easy i saw her in danger boys okay
so
i was not surprised she's very good
i did watch that but it's been a while
yeah thanks guys you're the best thank
you
um okay tiff back to you
uh tiff asks
what do you guys think our most
important similarity is
my like
like us to you like
it's it's so funny because there's so
many differences but there's also so
many parts when i'm hanging out with you
where i'm like you and i are the same
person this is really cool yeah like our
love for the world and going and
traveling around the world
um but the funny thing is when this when
this question popped up
the first thing the first image that
popped into my head was that one day
after all the girls left and you and i
just took a nap in my bed yeah yeah like
we were just laying there hanging out
waiting for something and then we both
just knocked out
and i think that was like one of the
sweetest moments with you and that's
like one of my favorite memories with
you too
[Laughter]
yeah
um
i think also
one of our similar traits is we really
like to take the time to appreciate
everything around us like we can take a
step back like when we were at uh the
wedding in in in paris and you and i had
a moment back
behind what is it when we were looking
at the view and we just held hands and
we like had a moment like i'm happy for
you dude yeah yeah that's my favorite
moment yeah that too yeah
that's so true
i
thought the first day it was like um
between us two
the the memories that stick out the most
are the like having like a more
child-like wonder
about the world like when i just had
this memory pop up on my phone
that was us like making hearts with the
sunset and like
running like
why is phoebe from friends coming up so
much
like looking like yeah
and we're just like we're having a blast
like doing this disney exploration thing
yeah
all right and then we were talking about
like all these bucket list things that
we were gonna do in l.a but then i moved
out of ballet but and the whole pandemic
happened the pandemic happened first and
then yeah we're trying to do all these
things around here because that's true
we do share that we share that like
childlike wonder
within us where we're just like let's
explore and like [ __ ] what we look like
and let's have fun like even when we
were talking about on the last episode
uh like we were all doing on zoom with
the disneyland thing and that these
[ __ ] didn't want to go to disneyland
and we're like yeah
all the disneyland that is my most
important shirt quality with you yeah we
don't like disneyland
[Music]
and kids listen i'm not a disney nerd
but like i love looking at like new
disneyland like a china or a
japan disney or a tokyo and a paris
disney i'm like
i want to see a paris disney yeah the
castle there is my favorite the pirates
same thing it just smells like
cigarettes no girl sleeping beauty
castle oh my god no it's awesome i love
it
i do have a paris here in vegas that
smells like cigarettes for sure yeah
confused
that's true
mine with tiff i think is just well and
we touched on this in a prior prior
episode is the fact that we can actually
have a conversation for a long period of
time and we enjoy talking to our friends
thank god you guys and i'll just put a
period on the end of that one yeah you
guys are more social yeah
i think well for me and you jess i love
how we're both like kind of control
freaks like ocd
mess with like
organizing and like
i don't know cleanliness is not like
cleaning it's not really my thing it's
definitely yours but like just
organizing you know like just
everything in order and everything makes
sense every time we're all together and
we do like airbnb kind of thing like
it's just me and you in the kitchen like
making sure everything's clean and like
picked up and like or like just
organized and i don't know i really love
that
that we share that
yes me too
there's at least one other crazy person
like me that's what i like yeah
i feel less crazy yeah that's exactly
what it is like my books are all
organized by color if you like that's i
mean like everything in my life is
organized but i don't go to an airbnb
and want to organize their show like
that's their [ __ ] like
you pay me if you want me to do that for
you but um
yeah i do like like the that about you
two to like the schedule like i like
bullet journaling and organizing things
but i don't clean
yeah
yeah yeah we know gina definitely does
no
i pay someone for that [ __ ] yeah yeah
you got the money you could pay
if i knew how to maybe be more rewarding
but i always feel like i work so hard
and i don't even do half a good his job
as like the cleaner
you know what i need it's like i need
someone to just set a structure for me
like this is where this goes this is
where this goes all the time
i was looking at you she was going to
start like a thing you should
that's what i did
i still think you should do that company
but maybe after after maybe
like provide a service
i don't know
you know it doesn't scale it doesn't
scale very well unless you hire like a
[ __ ] ton of people exactly maybe for
friends and family
yeah just like gina i'll come over and
i'll help you yeah
okay uh nikki
your card says what would be the perfect
gift for nicki
four more cats
some random crystals i'm going to start
going to like
random rocks and just bringing her rocks
like i think this is a crystal nicki
oh thank you
my friend brings my [ __ ] rocks off
the stream
so there was a bunch of crows outside
the g4 office and i bought a bag of
unsalted peanuts
they never came back oh
so they're just like they're just look
listen
wait i'm confused they never came back
because you're not readable
so like clothes you can make friends
with them and then they'll go and like
bring you gifts they'll go like get
tinfoil things for you
you bought [ __ ] 30 pounds of peanuts
because i was going to bring them in the
next day
and like feed them
yeah and then you're going to come back
you and nicki are a lot more alike than
i realized
she gets me yeah
so like you can like want to be friend
them over time and then they start
bringing you gifts and like if you
reject the gift they start bringing you
different gifts and then when you accept
it so like if they bring you a quarter
like yes more of these and you accept it
then they're like oh [ __ ] she likes
quarters and so they'll bring her
[ __ ] quarters or dollars and like all
kinds of [ __ ] like
they gift you how do you befriend them
other than feeding them you just keep
feeding them at the same time every time
it's better to befriend i did a lot of
research
i had a whole plan dude
i had a whole plan i wanted my i wanted
my gang of my murder of crows
attacked you for interns you know like i
was ready for this i was actually better
i heard if you befriend a couple because
if you befriend a whole murder they will
follow you around everywhere
and all their family members they teach
their family members like you're the one
that will go that will feed them and
after you stop feeding them then they
get pissed at you and they start
attacking you so that's why they're
called just a couple just a couple like
just two how do you control how many
you're like yes
usually like local so they they have
their territorial and so like they like
the local ones that come to your
backyard are like that's their territory
so you could befriend it's the same
crows every time because they're that's
their territory they claimed there's
like a gang of them those are like
[ __ ] loiterers
those are
honestly something about gina with like
30 crows following her around kind of
works
big outfits that you wear yeah totally
on brand and like can you imagine like
when i die at my funeral it's gonna be
like 500 crows it'll be like the coolest
funeral ever you know
but you guys won't be off they would be
all sad
you guys won't be able to hear the
eulogy because they won't shut the [ __ ]
up
she gave us the best peanuts
she gave the best peanuts
reporters we were supposed to be
answering what's the best gift to give
for nikki okay so
yeah
also a few crows
yeah
yeah so we said kitten uh crows just
animals in general
what i would give what i would give
nikki is i would i would pay for her
buy-in for her next tournament oh that's
like yeah that's a good one not the ten
thousand dollars
[Laughter]
various like kitchen appliances that are
really cool
yeah yeah there's a thermomix that does
like everything right now oh yeah
thermal mixer she was telling us last
time but nikki breaks all of her kitchen
appliances
yeah
i could tell you what would be the best
gift
wait let us know
yeah
um because i'm just thinking of what
i've given you in the past
you're a good gift picker
really yeah oh man i tried candles and
stuff no so i gave her i gave you a
mixology based on your astrology
book like it's called astrology yeah
cocktails it's such a perfect book
yeah i also gifted her
petrified wood yes because that was cool
specific because we had been talking
about that yeah like we were talking
about how [ __ ] cool it is and like
there was a whole thing that we watched
on it so like
she actually went there and got a piece
i went to the petrified forest and i was
like i have to bring nikki back that
sounds like bad luck to me shut up jess
the word petrified
you don't get us
taking something magical like petrified
wood out of its home it sounds like it
was a gift shop i paid for it so it's
fake there's yeah it was it was okay
it was purchased
i didn't steal it
it's
dead it's
it's magical it's not it's a stone it's
like a gem it's really cool it's like
yeah it's like a tree that's made out of
crystal
yeah
anyway
i
are you ready
i'm not much of a gift person because i
you know like i'm not that's all i would
love language but you like to give gifts
i do that you're really good i love gift
i like because i should not give person
either but
i would
like honestly steve brought this up one
time i think it was i think steve
brought it up but
if money wasn't a thing like you could
just get anyone any gift um
it would definitely be to have eminem
perform like my birthday party like a
private performance like some sort of
experience like whereas i'm at like a
private show the most expensive i know
what it would be
i know it'd be it would be a uh a like
week-long vacation at a tropical place
like bali where eminem comes and
performs yeah there's wild kittens
running around yeah yeah wild kittens
everywhere
and this is like littered with petrified
wood yeah no no like there's like a
place where you can go and dig up gems
and get your own crystals
gems
yeah i love it this is my dream life i
love this island
there we go taking me there yeah yeah
and then filled with um oh and then
there's like a section there's a whole
wing of this place that's all dedicated
to crafts and another wing all dedicated
to uh poker like
she gets to play poker with eminem it's
just that's it's like that is
for when she gets too socialed out she
can go sit in here yeah
deprivation yeah yeah she can still be
we're listening to you guys enjoy
yourself yeah part of it but we don't
talk to us yeah
too much stimulation but we're there we
love that you guys are having fun
exactly lots of alcohol oh wait no no
more alcohol yeah well unless there's
poker yeah if you're doing poker and
alcohol whenever there is no poker
there's alcohol yeah you have your own
private bartender following you
everywhere giving you something crazy i
love this i want the chef from that
restaurant we went to in vegas the last
day that we were there that [ __ ] was
bomb yeah which one which restaurant was
that the one by the lake yeah america oh
yeah that place was good that [ __ ] was
good
yeah fly him out yeah
uh okay jess
your card says um why don't you think
that we met
was this some like existential [ __ ] yeah
so so are we asking jess why she thinks
she met all of us or why she just
asking us
why do you think that we met jess
well yeah that is pretty random because
i was never supposed to be in this
industry yeah
so we definitely met for a reason yeah
and we're supposed to know the reason
i feel like we met for like a lot of
reasons like we needed
a core
group of girls to talk to
and we needed each other to like
yeah each of us were just problems in
our friends
yeah
we balance each other out i think like
for instance like
i i feel like i met jess so she can help
me stop freaking out about things or
teach me things
or and then like i i met nikki
so that she can teach that teach me like
it's okay to be
[ __ ] how weird i am
and then i met tiff so that she can
teach me that uh maybe having kids is
maybe nothing sort of
but just specifically
it's like i think it's to learn that um
it's
not so scary
being out there like kind of alone in
the world because like you grew up in a
rough
kind of like a rough situation like me
and
i get so scared of so many things and
when i hit you up you're like ah dude
it's cool
and then
most other people would be like oh no
it's okay don't worry don't cry whatever
whatever you're like no dude it's cool
stop it i'm like yeah dude it's cool
stop it all right i'm good
yeah i think each of us is the teacher
and the student
yeah what's your cat doing you should
eat the microphone
this is my nibbler
it's funny until her audio cuts out
everything out like your grounded
presence
uh yeah you know gina and i can be kind
of flighty and
kind of you're more grounded you
definitely like help the show run so
much better because yeah there's times
where everyone's just all over the place
you're like hey we gotta get [ __ ] done
now we're like oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and you're like i don't think i add
value because i don't like that's not
that big of a deal it's like no that's
actually a big a really big deal because
like we
leave it to us three to nine get any
[ __ ] done yeah
i'm wondering if you guys have any idea
like why i wound up here knowing like my
life i think you needed it and the fact
that i didn't yeah that's that's kind of
brings up
i wonder why i even wound up here at all
i remember when you first started it
like jacob where you first were entered
to the group and you didn't even want to
be on camera any not only did you not
want to be on camera but you didn't
think you'd be good at being on camera
with big mood first or when it was hey
[ __ ] like first started you're like i
don't know i just don't know what i
would say like i'm not gonna be a good
host and then you ended up being like
one of the people like bringing in the
episodes the topics everything and i
think that you kind of needed this like
almost like a boost in confidence that
you're that people do want to hear your
voice that people do think what you say
matters because i think it's very clear
from the audience and people are writing
in and people commenting on the show
that like a hell a lot of people relate
to you and
i think before you just kind of thought
that maybe no one understood what you
had to say or maybe you're just too
blunt about things and people don't get
it or whatever and then now you see like
actually people really value that and
people relate to it and i don't think
you would have gotten that before like
in your corporate setting i think that
you were in like you know
a male dominated corporate world where
you had to be a certain way there was
not a lot of creativity there and like
you had to really balance out what you
had to what how to say things you know
and do things a certain way and in a
creative world it's kind of like you
were thrown into this like fish out of
water environment where like
you know there aren't as many rules and
like you it it's almost
scary because you're so not used to that
but now you kind of get a bit of both
and
i think that you needed that kind of
balance in your life yeah that
experience people miss you when you're
gone dude we have comments all the time
yeah
i know you're so important to this show
jess like
it's just
you gotta see that yeah you gotta see
that seriously
okay um
oh actually just why do you think you
met us
that is yeah that's kind of like going
along with the question that i had um
i do think that i've definitely grown
like
so much
um in the experience that i've had not
only from the relationship that i had
but then like meeting all of you and
even all the people that i don't even
talk to anymore like every single person
that i was around kind of
helped mold me into a different person
even the audience helped mold me into a
different person
um and and by that being like it it's
okay to take criticism a little bit more
i think i like it was really impossible
for me to take criticism before and now
i've had to take so much of it that it
it's a little bit easier to swallow
and i think that's a good thing to have
in your life but you guys specifically
yeah i think it was like
i've always had friends but um
never been able to have like multiple
friends like all at once it's always
just been one for one friend here one
friend there and like getting to be a
part of like a group
was also like a pretty cool experience
something that
i needed to have i think too
um
but yeah i don't know it's i mean
obviously things happen for a reason and
i think i'm better off for having met
all of you like individually for
different reasons
um
it's definitely made me a better person
for sure
and i like myself more now than i ever
did i see that like
having you guys i feel like i when i met
you you had like a lot lower confidence
and now like i just see you glowing and
thriving and like
i just feel like
i watched that progression throughout
the show and it was really cool to see
i think you guys made me stronger um
like i was always kind of a harsh [ __ ]
right but like you guys made me
stronger just in the fact that i finally
kind of felt
loved too like i mean i have family and
stuff that love me but it's almost like
when the outside when someone outside of
your family can love you too then it
helps you feel like oh i am worthy of
love too and you guys have given me that
so i think i definitely needed that a
lot
i love you jess yay
yeah
don't cry little [ __ ] stop making me
feel feelings
[ __ ] you guys
[Laughter]
mellower vibes are a moment away with
dead grass they'll take you back to a
time when music was on vinyl books were
bought in stores and hipsters were just
a style of jeans and to celebrate the
passage of time they are doing a special
collab with george harrison's estate to
mark 50 years since his all things must
pass album dad grass is legal organic
smokeable hemp that relaxes your body
and mellows your mind they're 100
organic pre-rolled joints are very low
in thc and high in cbd so you can enjoy
the effects of cbd while keeping a clear
head that way you can chill out without
getting stoned it's like having a glass
of wine and not the whole bottle and dad
grass knows you get by with a little
hemp from a friend they've partnered
with the george harrison estate to
create a new cbd and cbg blend an
accessory is called all things musk
grass which pays tribute to the man who
always lets the good times roll all dead
grass products are federally legal for
ages 21 and over and it ships right to
your door anywhere in the u.s whether
you're looking for a new buzz or a chill
way to enjoy an old favorite dad grass
will leave you in a euphoric mood right
now dad grass is offering our listeners
20 off your first order when you go to
dadgrass.com big mood go to dadgrass.com
big mood for 20 off your first order
that's dadgrass.com
big mood people in the same ones
the cards are supposed to have like way
more different stuff yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ]
uh do you believe everyone has a calling
if so do you think i found mine
definitely
no no i think you're about to do
something else you know it's not [ __ ]
cut out for you
gaming right for you network tv
i don't know if that suits you nerd [ __ ]
all right we'll skip that one too back
to you
maybe
shouldn't we still be better
you should get a better one
how would you describe me to a stranger
oh god
what was that
where do i even start
she's she's probably one of the coolest
people you'll ever meet oh that's for
sure
yeah the most badass
most uh
the softest hands you've ever thought
she doesn't pick up any objects she's
got like princess fingers
i think you described yourself as an
eight-year-old boy inside of a like a
hot sexy female girl's body
it's pretty accurate
because why doesn't the inside match the
outside when i burp really loud
[Laughter]
yeah i've heard multiple people describe
you as like their little brother in a
hot girl's body and i'm like yeah
yeah
i've been um people at g4 the audience
at g4 compares me to like a feral
gremlin
that is funny what is even a gremlin
that's not even a real thing like this
gross little feral gremlin just like the
one thing you can't give water
pretty much yeah she doesn't drink water
exactly
they're right yeah
nailed it i'm glad i still have soft
hands though what the soft i'm a gremlin
with soft hands yeah your hands are
moist girl
yeah you're all right tip
smart and creative and
beautiful and you are like fiercely
loyal and you s you
aren't gonna take anyone's [ __ ] but
you're also just like really so like
well we won't tell people yourself so i
wouldn't talk to that
but don't tell the stranger that yeah
don't let them know yeah you can't let
it out don't find out yeah you'll just
have to see for yourself
you could ask according to nicki
probably i have adhd
she's literally fbi over here that's
true this is true
i'm proud of you jess i'm proud of what
you did earlier
you taught me that i was good to meet
you
to learn how to go to people finder and
search people
dig up information
all right tiff um i'm gonna pull these
cards because the three section is very
small and there's like wild cards
where like you have to do activity
you could do a little shuffle there if
you want get something good
okay um here's one for tiff
tiff asks
you guys what can i help you with like
what can tiff help us with
learning how to wear more color and
accessorizing
really yeah because i remember like when
all these years that i've worked with
you there are so many times when i'm
like wow
why don't she do that well she actually
changes jewelry every day
like she has colorful clothes like me
the jewelry i'm wearing is just like one
day if i happen to wear it i'll leave it
on
until like i have to take it off like a
shower
like rings or whatever yeah and then i
never put it back on you know what's
funny
like i i
think that's more me but then for you to
see me with different
like accessories it's like really i
don't think i do that but yeah you do
have a whole box of them remember yeah
yeah but i'll wear like one pair of
earrings for like weeks and weeks and
weeks and then like what like i'll
switch up sometimes i'll switch up like
necklaces
but now ever since having luca i don't
even wear anything anymore like i don't
even wear this ring usually i just ended
up putting your wedding is it yeah cause
like whenever i'm like trying to put him
in the crib or like like put my arms
under him like it gets stuck or like
sometimes his little hands are like
grabbing it or like yeah i'll like graze
my hand past him and it kind of
scratches him so i don't even wear my
wedding ring anymore
but anyways yeah and decorating
decorating and doing handy stuff putting
up a [ __ ] wallpaper you know
look at this look at this [ __ ] that i
have
none of this makes sense at least
at least it's uh not cluttered like yeah
i know the water's on my desk probably i
saw that light on shark tank was there
like 150 dollars does that that hard
light it wasn't a shark tank i don't
know they sent it to me oh no i think
they're shooting for my brother it's
like 150 or something it's expensive oh
yeah yeah but my desk is awesome lights
are expensive
yes like yeah i don't need yeah your
desk is
just me jesus like yours and steve's
desks are the same and i it gives me
anxiety
yeah
so i want to learn like
decorating organization from tiff oh
thanks because a lot of like i don't
know i've heard that my style is like
pick a style it's like it's all over the
place it looks like clutter it's
happening eclectic yeah i like it
that's a specific style [ __ ] those
people that's a style
style
i used to be more eclectic until i um
like i was like oh i guess i could just
do one accent color and then i started
like getting into specific styles but
like i i like eclectic
especially yeah it's like all the things
that make you happy and it doesn't look
too cluttered or like too like noisy
right you know it looks
cohesive to me
thanks because that's it yeah i think
organizing for sure
because i like to organize but
i think you're better at creating
systems for organizing you know and
actually like uh almost like micro
organizing like how you have those
drawers and like the drawer like i'll
put everything of one type in a drawer
like okay it's organized and i'll make
sure it's like
neatly like tetris in there but like you
have like actual like like bins and then
this dividers yeah
like all that stuff yeah that's just
another level
that's so cool
i'm trying to think because tiff and i
are are so alike in that way yeah we are
well but i think you have more
you probably have more style than i do i
would say i'm like the organized and
clean but i think you have more style
and more color and more like
um interesting
pieces
that you choose
i really love your apartment like the
one that you had
the one right before marina oh the other
one oh that was the oh yeah what was
that one called i really like that one
how you decorated it the child actor the
child yeah
yeah that was cute i really liked your
style i'm like oh that's so cute yeah it
was it was too cute for me it was too
cute for me and it's
a feather lamp yeah i got rid of that
i think that that was during the time in
your life where you were like
embracing your femininity for the first
time like you were like oh and that's
when you started dying your hair and
like you
i think you needed like to go that like
the pendulum to swing that far to be
like okay we'll dial it back a little
bit yeah it was like a little too girly
for me
nikki how does one earn your
vulnerability have we earned it and how
can we earn more um well i've been
asking this for i'm kidding
jess you see me cry more than any
[ __ ] person like
i've seen you cry more than we've seen
anyone else cry period
exactly
that's not enough i'm kidding usually i
go to the bathroom to do it in front of
for other people but for you guys i cry
right in front of you so yes you earned
it um
i would say like i earned it or caused
it
well if
i don't think i don't know like if
there's a trigger like i don't
necessarily think anyone causes it other
than like it triggering some sort of
thing that i've had to deal with um
but i think more than anything uh if i
feel
understood
or validated in feeling an emotion
rather than judged by it then i feel
more comfortable being vulnerable in
front of someone because
i've for all my life just felt immense
misunderstanding like i do something
someone's mad i don't know why they're
mad like i don't know why they're mad
and now i feel like very guilty but i
don't know how to correct it and like
it's i've talked about this before and
like it
really hurt a lot and like was kind of
traumatizing and like and the way that i
didn't really want to open up to other
people because i didn't know if like if
you get to know me better
i will randomly say something that hurts
you or something and then i won't know
what i did or said or whatever and then
you'll just randomly not be my friend
and all like i got like this sense of
like abandonment that's like abandonment
issues even though
like i personally have never been like
abandoned by like a parent or anything i
just felt like people who i had gotten
really close to like
i opened up to them and then they're
gone and i don't know why and
so
i feel like if at least
you can understand me on a deeper level
or like even if you don't agree like you
can still validate why like i might
feel a certain way or like if i made you
upset you can vocalize it or communicate
it in a way that helps me understand
what i did to make you upset so that i
can
help and like say sorry or like
understand like not to do certain things
like
it just like helps so much because i
can't figure it out like i think it's
part of like
i don't know maybe neurodivergency or
whatever but i don't know why but i
i just i've always felt like
like man i really
only want to help people are like the
best for people and like so when i say
something that like makes them upset it
like really
like gets like ugh
all you people watching need to stop
watching because you don't you didn't
earn this vulnerability
cut it out right this way
okay like cut it like take the tier edit
them out um
yeah we're putting it behind the paywall
they have to pay to see this page
[Laughter]
make some money off this
or it just runs from your face to your
neck down to your titties yeah just
there you go nipples with tears
i feel like you know that uh that video
that went viral of that girl
the little kid the little kid girl
that's crying and the mom's like what's
wrong she's like something
and they're like she's like you're
crying you're like i'm not crying i'm
laughing
yeah
that's me in front of everybody when i
don't want to be crying
[Laughter]
yeah that's pretty good um yeah i think
that's how you and i are similar like we
need proper communication to understand
what's going on because sometimes we
don't understand like uh like way in the
beginning i remember nikki said
something when we were filming that was
supposed to be private and then oh yeah
instead of like not talking what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] i just pulled her
aside i was like hey can you not say
that she's like yeah oh my god i'm so
sorry and it was fine sometimes it's all
just like that's what people need just
communication and i appreciate that so
much i was like i'm so sorry it's like
yeah thank you
i like it when you're vulnerable
like it's like the sweetest thing
like i'm like sometimes i'll describe
you guys to like my friends that haven't
met you yet
and i'm like
nikki's like the nicest thing in the
whole entire world like there's no way
that you cannot
like her like she cries the drop of a
hat she cries for no reason
you know like like there's no way that
she can ever do anything mean to you
because the thought of it would make her
cry yeah
she can't be me so it's like that's how
you know you can trust her because she
would just cry all the time you think
about people that stopped talking to me
10 years ago and i'm like i think i know
the moment that they stopped it was
because i said this but
i didn't mean that and i don't know how
to tell them now because they stopped
talking to me for so long ago but
i wish i could tell them that it wasn't
about them
yeah
yeah
yeah now it's more like if it ever
happens it's like you you know you said
like if someone were to come to me like
hey nikki said this and blah blah blah
i'll be like yo you need to understand
she's got a dash of tissue
you know
ten percent a little little sprinkle of
tissue
like crows
she probably doesn't even know that she
said something she doesn't get it you
know just tell her
and it should be like oh [ __ ] i'm so
sorry but just like bring some tissues
i love how much we figured each other
out yeah
after all these years i think it's the
cutest thing i'm so happy for that
like i remember someone like uh someone
that i dated in the past
met jess
the first time he met jess he was like
she's kind of mean and i remember just
what did i say i never got you never
told me what i said
because i know there's probably a lot of
[ __ ] there's probably a lot of [ __ ] that
you said about this person or like
straight to his face too yeah and after
we left he said she's kind of mean and i
remember the first thing i said was just
give her some time you'll see just keep
some time and then the second time i met
you he was like okay yeah she's pretty
cool like i told you just give it some
time i wonder what i said yeah but i
don't know if i did say something mean
it was probably because underneath i
knew yeah
it was yeah
like
there's something in you it's like i
sniffed the crotch [ __ ]
jess has always been right yeah every
time for a shitty person every time
like how do you know yeah he's like a
girl i'm like a metal detector but for
shitty dudes i want to take you on every
first date now
all right next card is for jess
what do you think just fears the most
get honest uncertainty
this [ __ ] has to be certain about
everything
losing her daddy
yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's probably the worst one i was
i was sitting with my cousins uh two
weekends ago we were having dinner
um and i was like somehow we got to the
topic of uh because they're both of
their oh all of our moms have died like
me and my three cousins they're a bit
older than me though so their moms died
like a little bit more like normal age i
guess but so all three of us are moms
died and i was just like
y'all if my dad does you're gonna have
to come find me and [ __ ] and like
watch me for like a straight month
because i'm gonna be [ __ ] up mm-hmm so
yeah that one's definitely but
very true too nikki uncertainty um
that's definitely a daily fear
more so than like a
overarching like the worst one ever but
yeah
yeah oh i didn't give an answer um
what is just fear the most
other than those two because i was
thinking those two yeah
those are probably the biggest ones
yeah i was thinking
too i was like being in the wrong seat
on a plane
and something happens i'm like the
alanis morissette song i'm like afraid
to feel afraid to fly
something happens to her in her house
and no one can find her because it's
just her and her dogs yeah i remember
that actually i don't even have my dogs
anymore my dad has adopted them because
he's retired now
so basically i'm like alone in my
apartment did you get you got mad
because they broke your finger huh
no
i did break my finger and it's still red
because it's red every day because i
have to like break down the [ __ ] oh
my god
yeah
yeah no yeah he's retired now and he has
a lot more time and he has a full yard
and i'm still in an apartment do you
miss them
i do it's
but also i feel guilty because i am
working a full-time job now and also
trying to date and also trying to go out
with friends so it's like i'm really not
home like compared to where i was in the
pandemic like home 24 7 to now
it's better for them i think to be
oh with my dad have you been hanging
with your friends that you know like
before you moved over here to us like
have you been hanging out with like your
old friends and stuff well i only have
one friend left in austin but i have
seen her several times yeah okay but i
also made some like work friends or
whatever but they're a little bit
younger so i don't know if it'll stick
they're like late twenties
did you come up with anything jeff
oh uh [ __ ] she's out there right now
her brain somewhere else yeah we nailed
it yeah yeah you guys got the craziest
ones no but i don't know
this doesn't count
friends
keep your wrath away from me
there's only so many
yeah
[ __ ]
all right well i hope you guys enjoyed
us playing this i love this game so much
and i want to buy the expansion packs
i've also heard of another game that's
similar like this called skin deep so i
might get that first to play also but um
i hope you guys enjoyed this episode and
getting to know us
and seeing nikki cry again
i feel like this game is called how long
until nikki cries yeah
[Laughter]
make sure you guys check out our
sponsors in the description buy
something you broke [ __ ] i love you uh
and we'll see you next week be good
don't talk to strangers we love you bye
[Music]
you